aquí en moscú las conversaciones para
lograr un alto el fuego nagorno karabakh
se prolongan por más de ocho horas
siguen reunidas las delegaciones armenia
y azerbaiyán a en una reunión presidida
por el ministro ruso de asuntos
exteriores sérguei lávrov el objetivo es
lograr un alto el fuego aunque sea
temporal se habla a estas horas de la
posibilidad de un cese del fuego de unas
72 horas el tiempo suficiente para que
ambos bandos puedan intercambiar los
cuerpos de los soldados muertos que ya
se cuentan por cientos y también
intercambiar prisioneros de guerra pocos
sabemos sobre lo que está pasando en el
edificio de el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores pero ha habido varias pausas
y en una de las primeras se ha visto a
la delegación hacia vayan a abandonar
las negociaciones aunque afortunadamente
poco después han vuelto a las
conversaciones está siendo muy difícil
acercar posturas tanto a armenia como
azerbaiyán ya habían anunciado que no
iban a ceder un milímetro en lo que se
refiere a su disputa territorial por
nagorno karabaj o